good afternoon and independent review
Into The departure of the Met Police
Commissioner Dame Cressida dick has Fel
has found that she felt intimidated into
stepping down that was following an
ultimatum issued by the London mayor
Sadiq Khan the report by Sir Tom Windsor
is a former Chief Inspector of
constabulary also concluded that due
process was not followed by the mayor
and that his actions did not comply with
the relevant legislation well we can go
live now to New Scotland Yard and skies
shingy marariki it makes fairly uh
interesting reading doesn't it this
report is there's a lot of it 100
something pages shingy but it doesn't
look good on face value for the London
mayor
no that's right that report has proven
divisive it's commissioned by the Home
Secretary Priti Patel she asks that Tom
Windsor former Chief Inspector of
constabulary to look into the facts
surrounding Crest the Dick's designated
resignation in February and to look at
how that process took place and whether
any legal any any laws were broken and
whether any any processes around that
could be improved that was released just
over an hour ago and it finds that he
believed that due process was not
followed by the mayor of London and
mayor's office for policing a crime in
the actions they took ahead of cress the
Dick's resignation it also notes that
the mayor's actions were not in
accordance with relevant legislation and
then most damning of all it goes on to
state that Dame Crest the dick felt
intimidated into stepping down from her
post as I say it has proven divisive and
right off the back of that we had
response from City Hall a statement from
Sadiq Khan which reads as follows the
mayor of London said that londoners will
be able to see that this review is
clearly biased and ignores the facts it
goes on London has elected me to hold
the Met Police Commissioner to account
and that's exactly what I have done I
make absolutely no apology for demanding
better for London and for putting the
interest of the city I love first and
coming back to that resignation it was
off the back of the series of scandals
which left her in the mayor of London at
loggerheads and in his response which we
have there's some additional reference
to some of those scandals that took
place before her resignation including
the murder of Sarah verrard by a serving
police officer Wayne cousins failings in
the investigation into Daniel Morgan and
also it's uh it's some allegations of
what it describes as racism sexism
misogyny homophobia and discrimination
exposed the exposed at Charing Cross
police station which left public trust
in the met at an all-time low according
to them and we've also seen some
background guidance from sources in City
Hall who are upset about so Thomas winds
is so Tom Windsor's involvement in this
and and they are saying that he has come
out in public before this in support of
crested dick and the conservative
government so it's quite clear even
though we now have a new commissioner in
place in the former Sir Mark Riley that
this report the res and the
circumstances around the resignation of
crest of the dick I've proved highly
divisive and will continue to provoke
some debate
yeah I was just going to say I mean it's
pretty incendiary stuff isn't it uh
Shinji the response from the London
mayor in response to it what happens now
with this report and presumably ends up
on the desk of the Home Secretary
yes so it was originally published as a
draft which the Home Secretary had seen
but because of the public interest in
the matters behind it we had it
published in full today
um as far as Sadiq Khan goes there's
already some clamor from conservative
members of the London assembly around
this for him to make some form of public
apology which I have here Susan Hall the
leader of the conservatives of the
London assembly according him to
apologize after after that report and
particularly the fact that Chris the
dick felt intimidated and that all the
conservative members of the London
assembly have called on Mr Khan to make
a formal apology so it's quite clear
that this will run and run for a while
now
all right shiny thank you